well how was your time you spent three
and a half
months
at rigers how was that how was your
experience in prison
how's the food from a chef perspective
not good but rikers was
um
when i got to write because i
so
i was arrested i spent i think about 10
days in a tennessee small town tennessee
jail
um
oh pigeon forge is also the weirdest
place on earth is it a town yes that's
the town where i was arrested why is it
so weird um
in the film they i told them i told them
you have to go to pigeon forge you have
to go there you have to go there and i
would think i was pushing them because
it was
going to potentially be
the end of the season
it's like a summer time or it's a
tourist destination
and it's so bizarre and weird and trippy
that
um
it doesn't even seem real seems like a
carnival is happening there non-stop
exactly it's it's car i think i say that
in my intro that it's carnivalesque and
trippy and weird
is there a lot of clowns walking around
or not necessarily clowns but there is a
video on youtube that i
cause i got to the chapter where we
arrive in pigeon forge and i'll never
forget although i have forgotten but i
remember being
like
weirdly
like felt like we were had entered a
different universe driving down this
strip and just looking at everything on
either side and i'm wishing that i could
remember in more detail like the names
of the places or what was there because
i wanted to describe it um in this
chapter and i was like i wish somebody i
wish there was like a video of somebody
going down the street kind of showing
what's on one side and then the other
side and i was like
there probably is and there is on
youtube like i found it and i watched
the whole thing how does this come up
from prison exactly
um picture
oh okay
so that's the town that i went to jail
and
all right in tennessee right so what was
that like
the food there
and some of the conditions
the food
made when i got to
um that i was extradited and transferred
to rikers and when i got to rikers i
felt like it was like the four seasons
in comparison
wow so um and i i really kind of
appreciated a lot of things about
about new york when i got when i got to
rikers even though there are a lot of
things that are very scary about it
where's uh right located is it close to
new york city
yes and in a very
kind of
almost
poetically interesting way
the the dorm room where i was when i was
there for the three and a half months
was one of the ones that faced manhattan
so
i could go across the room and look out
the window and see the whole manhattan
skyline view
which was i remember being
shocked by
the cost
per prisoner per year
yes
that uh new york pays it's like 400 500
000 or something
i didn't think it was that much i
thought i wrote it down but either way
it is no i mean it it's elevated uh
during covid which is fascinating to
that the number i just said
yeah
during covet i felt sick to my stomach
thinking about people
stuck there and again so rikers isn't
like a long-term prison it's most of the
people at rikers are awaiting
trial
and they've been arrested but not
convicted and then if you're convicted
and you're sentenced to less than a year
then you put on a different color
uniform and you go upstairs to different
dorms
if you're convicted and sentenced to
more than a year you're sent to one of
the upstate prisons
so most of the people at rikers are
there in transition they've been
arrested but not
um
they've been arrested but not
convicted or awaiting trial so you could
be
perfectly innocent
and you're stuck there and that happens
to a lot of people
or you could be arrested
over some kind of
comparatively petty thing or non-violent
thing
and and stuck there because you don't
have as little as five hundred dollars
to pay
bail which is completely
messed up and unjust
and i think most people most reasonable
people agree that it's unjust
but it's different when you're there and
you see those people and you see
um kind of the anguish
and whether i mean i have no idea if
they're guilty of what i mean
i usually don't know what people are
there for or what the situation is but
you watch
the sort of
help helplessness set in
um
because you're kind of powerless there
you have very little contact with the
outside world you have these limited
phone calls
and so
for people who had kids in a job and an
apartment it's like one by one those
things are lost or their
kids are now being looked after by their
abusive ex-husband or something like
that and so watching that is just
gut-wrenching and then also
knowing that
the only reason they're unable to get
out is because of you know a thousand
dollars two thousand dollars in some
cases five hundred dollars there were
people
um
so there's all of these tragic cases but
then there was also
while i was there i mean if i'd had any
money i would have been wanting to bail
people out left and right and then in
some cases i think there was a woman
there snored really loud and her bail
was five hundred dollars and i was like
i wish i had a bail or she just wanted
to bail her out so
um because i'm pretty sensitive to
sounds and being in a room with 50
people inevitably
so you're in a room with a large number
of people yeah there are um
there are areas there with cells but a
lot of the areas there are
um
rooms with
50 beds so and they're about three feet
apart from each other so
during covet there was certainly no
social distancing
um and that just felt kind of
sickening especially because
so many people are there for
non-violent things or drug addiction
related or mental health issues
um how did that you personally just
having spent that time there for
three and a half months how did that
change you
like what
did that have an effect on your mind
on my mind personally i think i was
i was
surprised
at how
well i adapted and then how it was able
to um and then i think i sort of took it
a next level when one of the books
somebody sent me was um
the untethered soul by michael singer
and it's very much about like observing
your mind and um
that kind of
helped take it to next level so was this
like a meditation retreat for you
well it's like
it'd be like trying to meditate in the
middle of a circus or
in crazy circumstances because you're
never alone
there's nowhere to be alone and there's
always talking there's noises there's
fighting noises chaos um did you feel in
danger
yes but
um
i i never i never felt terrified there
um
you know one of my friends the bathroom
is the scary place because they don't
have cameras in the um
in the bathroom so that's sort of a
one has to watch out there and i did one
of my friends who i
one of the people i was friends with
there she did get
um beat up a bit in the bathroom
one day
a lot of weird [ __ ] happened in the
bathroom
um
but it was
from a if you're interested in human
behavior and psychology and
it's it can be fascinating to kind of
sit there and watch they're saying like
you might enjoy prison for that
perspective like just you get to watch
human nature it's
um
like at the
i don't want to say that it's worse but
like the full variety that it can
uh
take right and there was a lot of beauty
there as well i mean is there love
people being um
well again depends on the definition of
love but
people being you know incredibly
generous and kind to each other um
sometimes people singing at night
um
there was just a lot of
and then there was a lot of you know
hilarious stuff it's just it's all there
there's like there's tragic things
um
you know interesting things
a lot of people with mental health
issues which is um can be
difficult
to witness
you